This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On this show, we tell stories about what we make and what it says about us as humans. But we never rate those things on a five-star scale. The Anthropocene Review is here to correct that oversight. I love this show. It's by John Green, he's the author of Besseling Books, like The Fault in Our Stars and Turtles All the Way Down.
这里是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。在这个节目中，我们讲述关于我们制造的事物，以及这些事物如何定义人类自己的故事。但我们从来不会用五星评分制来为这些事物打分。《人类世观察》（The Anthropocene Review）就是来弥补这一疏忽的。我太喜欢这个节目了。它的创作者是约翰·格林（John Green），他是畅销书作家，著有《星运里的错》（The Fault in Our Stars）和《寻找阿拉斯加》（Looking for Alaska）等作品。
He also makes some of the best stuff on YouTube with this brother Hank. Today we're gonna feature two of my favorite episodes of his new podcast that I think will be of particular interest to a nine-in-9 PI listener. Plus, we'll have an interview with John about a lot of things like sports and learning to love pop music as an adult. I think you're really gonna like it.
他还和他的弟弟汉克（Hank）在YouTube上制作了一些最棒的内容。今天，我们将为您呈现他的新播客中最我喜欢的两期节目，我认为这会引起9% PI听众的特别兴趣。此外，我们还将对约翰进行一次采访，内容涵盖很多方面，比如体育运动，以及作为一个成年人如何学会去热爱流行音乐。我想你们一定会非常喜欢。
After I got done talking with John, I just felt good all day about life. That was great. But first, here's an episode of the Anthropocene Reviewed. Hello and welcome to the Anthropocene Reviewed, a podcast where we review different facets of the human-centered planet on a five-star scale. Today, I'll be reviewing a 17,000-year-old painting and the Taco Bell breakfast menu. Let's start with the painting. So, if you've ever been or had a child, you will likely already be familiar with hand stencils. They were the first figurative art made by both our kids, somewhere between the ages of two and three, my children spread the fingers of one hand out across a piece of paper, and then, with the help of a parent, traced their five fingers. I remember my son's face as he
在我跟约翰聊完之后，我整整一天对生活都感觉很好。那太棒了。但首先，这是一期《人类世观察》。你好，欢迎收听《人类世观察》，这是一个以五星评分制来评价人类中心星球各个方面的播客。今天，我将评测一幅有17,000年历史的壁画和塔可钟（Taco Bell）的早餐菜单。让我们从这幅画开始。所以，如果你曾经是一个孩子，或者养育过孩子，你可能对手印stencil已经很熟悉了。这是我们两岁到三岁之间的孩子创作的第一批具象艺术，我的孩子们把一只手的手指张开摊在纸上，然后在父母的帮助下描摹出他们五根手指的轮廓。我记得我儿子的脸，当他
lifted his hand and looked absolutely shocked to see the shape of his hand still on the paper, a semi-permanent record of himself. I am extremely happy that my children are no longer three, and yet to look at their little hands from those early artworks is to be inundated with a strange soul-splitting joy. Those pictures remind me that they are not just growing up, but also growing away from me, running toward their own lives. But of course, that's meaning I am applying to their hand stencils, and that complicated relationship between art and its viewers is never more fraught than when we are looking deeply into the past.
抬起手，看到纸上依然留着自己手的形状时，他露出了极其震惊的表情，那是他存在的一个半永久性记录。我感到无比高兴，因为我的孩子们不再是三岁了，然而看着他们早期艺术作品中的小手，却会被一种奇异的、撕裂灵魂的喜悦所淹没。这些画作提醒我，他们不仅在长大，也在离开我，奔向他们自己的生活。但当然，这是我赋予他们手印的意义，艺术与其观赏者之间那种复杂的关系，在我们深入回望过去时，表现得尤为强烈。
In September of 1940, an 18-year-old mechanic named Marcel Ravi Dott was walking his dog robot in the countryside of southwestern France when the dog disappeared down a hole. Robot eventually returned, but the next day Ravi Dott went to the spot with three friends to explore the hole, and after quite a bit of digging, they discovered a cave with walls covered with paintings, including over 900 paintings of animals, horses, stags, bison, and also species that are now extinct, including a woolly rhinoceros. The paintings were astonishingly detailed and vivid with red, yellow, and black paint made from pulverized mineral pigments that were usually blown through a narrow tube,
1940年9月，法国西南部乡村，一个18岁的机械师名叫马塞尔·拉维多（Marcel Ravidat），正带着他的狗“机器人”（Robot）在散步，当时狗掉进了一个洞里。机器人后来回来了，但第二天拉维多带着三个朋友来到这个地点探索这个洞，经过一番挖掘，他们发现了一个洞穴，洞壁上画满了画，包括900多幅动物画，有马、鹿、野牛，还有一些现已灭绝的物种，包括披毛犀。这些画作异常详细且生动，使用了红、黄色和黑色的颜料，这些颜料是由粉碎的矿物颜料制成的，通常是通过一根细管子吹出来的，
possibly a hollowed bone, onto the walls of the cave. It would eventually be established that these artworks were at least 17,000 years old. Two of the boys who visited the cave that day were so profoundly moved by the art they saw that they camped outside the cave to protect it for over a year. After World War II, the French government took over protection of the site, and the cave was open to the public in 1948. When Picasso saw the cave paintings on a visit that year, he reportedly said, we have
可能是一根掏空的骨头，吹到洞穴的壁上。最终人们确认这些艺术品至少有17,000年的历史。那天参观洞穴的两个男孩被他们看到的艺术深深感动，以至于他们在洞外露营了一年多来保护它。二战后，法国政府接管了该遗址的保护工作，该洞穴于1948年对公众开放。当毕加索在那年参观时看到这些洞穴壁画时，据报道他说：“我们什么也没有创造。”
invented nothing. There are many mysteries at Lesco. Why, for instance, are there no paintings of reindeer? Which we know were the primary source of food for the paleolithic humans who lived in that cave. Why were they so much more focused on painting animals than painting human forms? Why are certain areas of the cave filled with images, including pictures on the ceiling that required the building of scaffolding to create, while other areas have only a few paintings. And where the painting's spiritual here are sacred animals, or where they practical, here is a guide to some of the animals that might kill you.
拉斯科（Lascaux）有许多谜团。例如，为什么没有驯鹿的画？我们知道驯鹿是住在那个洞穴里的旧石器时代人类的主要食物来源。为什么他们比画人类形态更专注于画动物？为什么洞穴的某些区域挤满了图像，包括需要在天花板上搭脚手架才能创作的画作，而其他区域却只有几幅画？这里的画作是精神性的，是神圣的动物，还是实用的，这里是一份可能会杀死你的动物指南？
Aside from the animals, there are nearly a thousand abstract signs and shapes we cannot interpret, and also several negative hand stencils, as they are known by art historians. These are the paintings that most interest me. They were created by pressing one hand with fingers split against the wall of the cave, and then blowing pigment, leaving the area around the hand painted. Similar hand stencils have been found in caves around the world, from Indonesia, to Spain, to Australia, to the Americas, to Africa. We have found these memories of hands from 15 or 30 or even 40,000 years ago. These hand stencils remind us of how different life was in the distant past. Amputations, likely from frostbite, are common in Europe, and so you often see negative
除了动物之外，还有近千个我们无法解读的抽象符号和形状，以及几个艺术史学家所称的负手印。这些是最让我感兴趣的画作。它们的创作方法是将一只手手指分开压在洞穴墙壁上，然后吹拂颜料，使手部周围的区域被涂上颜色。在世界各地的洞穴中都发现了类似的手印，从印度尼西亚、西班牙、澳大利亚、美洲到非洲。我们发现了这些来自1.5万、3万甚至4万年前的手部记忆。这些手印提醒我们，遥远过去的生命是多么不同。欧洲普遍存在因冻伤而导致的截肢，因此你经常会看到带有三根或四根手指的负面
hand stencils with three or four fingers, and life was short and difficult, as many as a quarter of women died in childbirth, around 50% of children died before the age of five. But they also remind us that the humans of the past were as human as we are, their hands indistinguishable from ours. These communities hunted and gathered, and there were no large caloric surpluses, so every healthy person would have had to contribute to the acquisition of food and water, and yet somehow they still made time to create art, almost as if art isn't optional for humans. We see all kinds of hand stenciled on cave walls, children, and adults, but almost always
手印，生活短暂而艰难，多达四分之一的女性死于难产，大约50%的儿童在五岁前夭折。但它们也提醒我们，过去的人类和我们一样具有人性，他们的手与我们无法区分。这些社群靠狩猎采集为生，没有大量多余的热量储备，因此每个健康的人都必须为获取食物和水做出贡献，然而不知何故，他们依然抽出时间来创造艺术，仿佛艺术对人类来说不是可有可无的。我们在洞穴墙壁上看到了各种各样的手印，有儿童的，也有成人的，但几乎总是
the fingers are spread, like my kids hand stencils. I'm no Jungian, but it's fascinating and a little strange that so many paleolithic humans who couldn't possibly have had any contact with each other created the same paintings the same way, paintings that we are still making. But then again, what the Lasco art means to me is likely very different from what it meant to the people who made it. Some academics theorize that the hand stencils were part of hunting rituals. Then there's always the possibility that the hand was just a convenient model situated at the end of the wrist. To me though, the hand stencils at Lescaus say, I was here.
手指张开，就像我孩子的手印一样。我不是荣格主义者，但令人着迷且有点奇怪的是，那么多不可能有任何接触的旧石器时代人类，却以同样的方式创作了同样的画作，这些画作我们今天仍在制作。然而话说回来，拉斯科艺术对我而言的意义，很可能与当年创作它的人所赋予的意义大不相同。一些学者推测，这些手印是狩猎仪式的一部分。当然，也存在这样一种可能，即手只是位于手腕末端的一个方便的模具。不过对我来说，拉斯科的手印仿佛在说：“我曾来过。”
They say, you are not new. And because they are negative prints surrounded by red pigment, they also look to me like something out of a horror movie, like ghostly hands reaching up from some bloody background. They remind me that, as Alice Walker wrote, all history is current. The Lasco Cave has been closed to the public for many years now. Too many contemporary humans breathing inside of it led to the growth of mold and lichens, which is damage some of the art. Just the act of looking at something can ruin it, I guess. But tourists can still
它们在说：“你并不新鲜。”因为它们是被红色颜料包围的负片印记，它们在我的眼里看起来也像是恐怖电影里的东西，就像从某种血腥背景中伸出的幽灵般的手。它们提醒我，正如爱丽丝·沃克（Alice Walker）所写的那样，所有历史都是现时的。拉斯科洞穴对公众关闭已经很多年了。太多当代人类在里面呼吸导致了霉菌和地衣的生长，这损坏了一些艺术品。我想，仅仅是观察某事物的这个行为，就能毁了它。但游客仍然可以
visit an imitation cave called Lasco 2, in which the artwork has been meticulously recreated. Humans making fake cave art to save real cave art may feel like peak anthropocene behavior, but I have to confess that even though I am a jaded and cynical semi-professional reviewer of human activity, I actually find it overwhelmingly hopeful that four teenagers and a dog named robot discovered a cave with 17,000 year old handprints, that the cave was so overwhelmingly beautiful that two of those teenagers devoted themselves to its protection, and that when we humans became a danger to that cave's beauty. We agreed to stop going. Last go is there.
参观一个被称为“拉斯科2号”的仿制洞穴，其中的艺术品被一丝不苟地重现了。人类为了拯救真正的洞穴艺术而制造虚假的洞穴艺术，这感觉像是人类世的巅峰行为，但我必须承认，尽管我是一个厌世且愤世嫉俗的人类活动半专业评论员，但我实际上发现，有四个青少年和一只名叫“机器人”的狗发现了一个拥有1万7千年历史手印的洞穴，这个洞穴是如此美得令人窒息，以至于其中两个青少年致力于保护它，而当我们人类成为该洞穴美景的威胁时，我们同意停止前往，这让我感到无比充满希望。拉斯科就在那里。
You cannot visit. You can go to the fake cave we've built, and see nearly identical hand stencils. But you will know, this is not the thing itself, but a shadow of it. This is a hand print, but not a hand. This is a memory that you cannot return to, all of which makes the cave very much like the past it represents. I give the hand print stencils at Lesco, 4.5 stars. A few weeks ago, a listener to this podcast named Stephen emailed me to ask if I would
你无法参观。你可以去我们建造的假洞穴，看到几乎完全相同的正负手印。但你会知道，这不是事物本身，而是它的影子。这是一个手印，但不是一只手。这是一段你无法回头的记忆，所有这一切使得这个洞穴非常像它所代表的过去。我给拉斯科的手印4.5星。几周前，这个播客的一位听众斯蒂芬（Stephen）发邮件问我是否会
consider reviewing the Taco Bell breakfast menu. And that seemed like a good idea, albeit one that would require me to eat a fair bit at Taco Bell, which is a fast food restaurant chain with over 7,000 restaurants around the world that was founded by a Marine Corps veteran named Glenn Bell. Glenn did not start out as a taco guy. After serving in World War II, he returned to his native Southern California to seek his fortune in the burger business.
考虑评测塔可钟的早餐菜单。这听起来是个好主意，尽管这需要我在塔可钟吃相当多东西，塔可钟是一家快餐连锁店，在全球拥有7000多家餐厅，由一位名叫格伦·贝尔（Glenn Bell）的海军陆战队退伍军人创立。格伦一开始并不是个卖塔可的人。在二战服役后，他回到家乡南加州，在汉堡生意中寻找发财的机会。
He ran a restaurant in San Bernardino called Bell's Drive-In in 1948. His business did okay, but across the street, a family-owned Mexican restaurant called the Meatla Cafe was selling lots of tacos, including its famous hardshell tacos. Bell would often eat at the Meatla Cafe and then go back to his hamburger stand and try to reverse engineer those popular tacos, but he could never figure it out. So eventually, he became friends with the family that owned the meatla, and they showed him the recipe. Bell started making tacos soon thereafter. Side note, the meatlaquefe was the setting for an important moment in American history.
1948年，他在圣贝纳迪诺（San Bernardino）经营一家名为“贝尔免下车”（Bell's Drive-In）的餐厅。他的生意还算过得去，但在街对面，一家名为麦特拉咖啡馆（The Mitla Cafe）的家族经营的墨西哥餐厅卖出了大量塔可，包括其著名的硬壳塔可。贝尔经常去麦特拉咖啡馆吃饭，然后回到他的汉堡摊，试图逆向工程那些受欢迎的塔可，但他怎么也搞不懂。因此最终，他与拥有麦特拉的家族成为了朋友，他们向他展示了配方。此后不久，贝尔就开始制作塔可。顺便说一句，麦特拉咖啡馆是美国历史上一个重要时刻的发生地。
In the early 1940s, public pools and other services were segregated in San Bernardino. Latinos couldn't swim at the pool, or sit in certain sections of movie theaters, some businesses had whites only signs, and many schools were segregated. In a series of meetings held at the Meatluck F.A., Latino church and civic leaders developed a plan to sue the city of San Bernardino. And they won. In fact, the case, Lopez versus Secum, was cited by the Supreme Court in its famous Brown versus Board of Education decision that found segregated schools to be illegal. We'll return to Taco Bell momentarily, but one last note about the meatlaquefe, it's
在20世纪40年代初，圣贝纳迪诺的公共游泳池和其他服务是实行种族隔离的。拉丁裔不能在泳池游泳，也不能坐在电影院的某些区域，有些企业挂着“仅限白人”的牌子，许多学校也是隔离的。在麦特拉咖啡馆举行的一系列会议上，拉丁裔教堂和公民领袖制定了一项起诉圣贝纳迪诺市的计划。他们赢了。事实上，最高法院在其著名的“布朗诉教育委员会案”判决中引用了“洛佩兹诉塞克姆案”（Lopez v. Secombe），该判决裁定隔离学校是非法的。我们将稍后回到塔可钟，但关于麦特拉咖啡馆还有最后一点，它
still open, and today is run by the fourth generation of the family who founded it. I've eaten there, actually, and it will not surprise you to learn that their tacos are vastly incalculably superior to Taco Bell tacos. But of course, Taco Bell isn't really in the business of being good. It aims to be good enough and consistent and inexpensive. Right, so of course, the recipe for Taco Bell tacos
至今仍在营业，今天由创立它的家族的第四代人经营。其实我在那儿吃过，你不会惊讶地发现，他们的塔可比塔可钟的塔可要好得多，简直无法估量。但当然，塔可钟的业务本质并不是为了追求“好吃”。它的目标是“足够好”、稳定且便宜。对，所以当然，塔可钟塔可的配方
was stolen by a white restaurant owner from a local center for Latino community and inexpensive. Right, so of course the recipe for Taco Bell Tacos was stolen by a white restaurant owner from a local center for Latino community and activism, but the owners of the meatlaquefe have never publicly expressed any resentment toward Bell. One member of the family, Irene Montano, magnanimously said of him, he was a self-starter, and he did push those Tacos. Indeed, after opening the first Taco Bell in Downey, California in 1962, new franchises of Taco Bell spread rapidly throughout the West Coast. Back then, the menu was extremely simple. Tacos, tostados, burritos, frijoles, and chili burgers, and everything cost 19 cents
是由一个白人餐厅老板从一个拉丁裔社区和激进主义的本地中心偷来的，但麦特拉咖啡馆的老板们从未公开对贝尔表达过任何怨恨。家族的一位成员伊琳娜·蒙塔诺（Irene Montano）大度地评价他说：“他是一个靠自己奋斗的人，而且他确实推销了那些塔可。”事实上，1962年在加州唐尼（Downey）开设第一家塔可钟后，塔可钟的新特许经营店在整个西海岸迅速蔓延。当时，菜单极其简单。塔可、玉米饼、卷豆饼、豆子和辣椒汉堡，每样东西都只要19美分
around a buck 50 in today's money. People loved it. By 1967, there were 100 taco bells, and there were 868 when Bell sold his company to PepsiCo in 1978 for $125 million. Selling Taco Bell, a loud glend, pursued the true passion of his life. A quarter-scale model train adventure park called Bell Gardens. Bell was a lifelong model train enthusiast, but the park, which had no rides that weren't quarter-scale model trains
以今天的物价计算大约是一美元五十美分。人们非常喜欢它。到1967年，已经有100家塔可钟（Taco Bell），而当贝尔在1978年以1.25亿美元将公司卖给百事公司时，已经有868家了。卖掉这个喧闹的餐饮品牌的塔可钟后，他去追求他一生的真正激情。一个名为贝尔花园的四分之一比例模型火车冒险公园。贝尔终生都是模型火车爱好者，但这个公园里除了四分之一比例的模型火车之外没有任何游乐设施
went bankrupt after a few years. I mention all of this because I think it's important to understand that Glen Bell was not like passionate about Mexican food. He saw an opportunity in a marketplace and he filled it. I'm not trying to bash Taco Bell. I've had many enjoyable meals there in my younger and less nutrition oriented days. And per dollar spent, Taco Bell offers more caloric energy than almost any other restaurant. A Big Mac at McDonald's delivers about 1.45 calories per penny spent.
几年后破产了。我提到所有这些，是因为我认为重要的是要理解格伦·贝尔并非多么热爱墨西哥食物。他在市场中看到了商机，然后填补了它。我不是在抨击塔可钟。在我更年轻、对营养不那么讲究的日子里，我在那里吃过很多令人愉快的饭菜。按花费的每一美元计算，塔可钟提供的热量几乎比任何其他餐厅都多。麦当劳的巨无霸每花一分钱提供大约1.45卡路里。
A Taco Bell beefy Fritos Burrito offers an astonishing 4.26 calories per penny. Also, I recently ate a Taco Bell beefy Fritos Burrito under the guise of research for this review, and for about 5 minutes after eating it, I felt almost euphoric. It was flavorful and intoxicating mix of crunchy and chewy, and strangely sweet. The beef was stringy, that tortilla sub-optimal, and I suspect I would be horrified by a thorough accounting of the environmental and sociopolitical costs of the beefy Fritos Burrito. But still, for those five minutes, I felt pleasantly and entirely satiated.
塔可钟的牛肉多力多滋卷饼（beefy Fritos Burrito）每花一分钱提供惊人的4.26卡路里。此外，我最近为了这次评测的研究，吃了一个塔可钟的牛肉多力多滋卷饼，在吃完后的大约5分钟里，我感觉几乎欣喜若狂。这是一种浓郁且令人陶醉的组合，既有脆脆的口感又有嚼劲，而且带着奇异的甜味。牛肉是丝状的，玉米饼不是最佳状态，我怀疑如果彻底核算牛肉多力多滋卷饼的环境和社会政治成本，我会感到震惊。但即便如此，在那五分钟里，我感到愉快且完全饱腹。
Ten minutes after that, of course, I began to feel extremely unwell, but that might be down to my generally weak constitution rather than any fault of the food itself. All I'm saying is that Taco Bell is not like a mission-driven institution. It seeks to turn a profit. And that's why I find it so fascinating that Taco Bell didn't serve breakfast until 2012. Burger King served its first breakfast in 1979. McDonald's introduced the egg McMuffin way back in 1972. Maybe Taco Bell was late to breakfast
当然，十分钟后，我开始感到极其不适，但这可能归咎于我普遍较弱的体质，而不是食物本身的任何问题。我只想说，塔可钟不是那种有使命驱动的机构。它旨在牟取暴利。这就是为什么我觉得很有趣的是，塔可钟直到2012年才供应早餐。汉堡王（Burger King）在1979年供应了第一份早餐。麦当劳早在1972年就推出了蛋满分（egg McMuffin）。也许塔可钟很晚才推出早餐
because they didn't want to recreate actual Mexican breakfast food, which is excellent, but bears very little resemblance to the hash browns and cinnamon flavored donut holes that Taco Bell eventually released as part of their breakfast menu. All of which goes to show, again, that Taco Bell eventually released as part of their breakfast menu. All of which goes to show, again, that Taco Bell as a company is not and never has been interested in Mexican food except for what could be efficiently appropriated from it, which is why the taste profile of its breakfast menu more closely resembles that of Burger
是因为他们不想重新制作真正的墨西哥早餐，那是非常棒的，但与塔可钟最终作为早餐菜单一部分推出的土豆饼和肉桂味甜甜圈球几乎没有什么相似之处。所有这些再次表明，塔可钟作为一家公司过去不是、现在也从不对墨西哥食物感兴趣，除非能从中有效地占为己有，这就是为什么其早餐菜单的口味特征比麦特拉咖啡馆的任何东西都更接近汉堡王。我认为甜甜圈球很好吃，但油炸面团很难做砸。我发现烤早餐卷饼（grilled breakfast burrito fiesta potato）和它的名字一样，有点过于复杂。对我来说最突出的是早餐克兰奇卷（breakfast crunch wrap），它将土豆饼、培根、鸡蛋和奶酪包裹在烤玉米饼里。这并不算坏，但大体上，我的塔可钟早餐正是塔可钟狂热且无休止的营销活动似乎最害怕的东西。它很无聊。
King than anything at the meat like afe. I thought the donut holes were good, but it's hard to mess up Fried Doe. I found the grilled breakfast burrito fiesta potato to be, like its name, a bit overcomplicated. The standout to me was the breakfast crunch wrap, which wraps hash browns, bacon, eggs, and cheese into a grilled tortilla. And that wasn't bad, but mostly my Taco Bell breakfast was what Taco Bell's frantic and relentless marketing campaigns seemed to fear the most. It was boring. I find it revealing that while there are Taco Bells in Romania and Australia and Brazil, you won't find one in Mexico. They've tried twice in 1992 and 2007, but both times, the restaurants face the same fate
我发现有启发性的是，虽然罗马尼亚、澳大利亚和巴西都有塔可钟，但在墨西哥你却找不到一个。他们在1992年和2007年尝试过两次，但每次这些餐厅都面临着与格伦·贝尔的铁路冒险乐园相同的命运。你可以在每个菜单项的末尾加一个元音，你可以把你的口号定为“Yokeiro Taco Bell”（我想要塔可钟）。但如果你不能在墨西哥卖出你的塔可，它们就不是墨西哥的。我给塔可钟早餐两颗星。
as Glen Bell's railroad adventure land. You can add a vowel to the end of every menu item and you can make your catchphrase, Yokeiro Taco Bell. But if you can't sell your tacos in Mexico, they ain't Mexican. I give the Taco Bell breakfast menu two stars. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background you what you do, what in the world do you say? I usually say that I work in educational videos so that they don't ask more questions. But if I'm feeling a little more talkative, I usually say that I'm a writer and a YouTuber.
你做什么，你在世界上说什么？我通常说我从事教育视频工作，这样他们就不会问更多问题了。但如果我感觉稍微健谈一点，我通常会说我是一个作家和一个YouTube博主。
Right. But I guess now I'm also a podcaster, so I don't know what I do. How do you describe the Anthropocene Review? The Anthropocene Review is a show where I look at different facets of the human-centered planet and then review them on a five-star scale. It started out as like a bit. It started out as a joke I had with my brother because of Yelp and Amazon reviews and good reads that everything now is reviewed on a five star scale and everything gets a thumbs
对。但我想现在我也是一个播客了，所以我也说不清我是做什么的。你如何描述《人类世观察》？《人类世观察》是一个节目，我观察以人类为中心的星球的各个方面，然后用五星评分制来评价它们。它最初就像是一个段子。它最初是我和弟弟因为Yelp、亚马逊评论和Goodreads（豆瓣读书的海外版）上的评论而开的一个玩笑，即现在所有东西都用五星评分来评价，所有东西都得到一个大拇指向上或向下，推荐或不推荐。如果我们把这种评价框架应用到交通锥上会怎么样？这就是我跟他开的最初玩笑，或者就像我们的所有袜子一样，汉克觉得：这很好，这是一个有趣的段子。所以我想他最后做了一个视频，在视频里他用了这个段子，然后我最终写了一篇关于健怡博士胡椒（Diet Dr Pepper）和大雁（Canada Geese）的文章。在写完这些文章后，我想，你知道，这其实不是很有趣。我本来以为这会是一件滑稽的事，但我喜欢它，它让我感兴趣。而且因为我的职业生涯是从书评人开始的，
up or a thumbs down, a recommend or a don't recommend. And what if we applied that reviewing framework to like traffic cones, and that was the initial joke that I made with him or like our guy all socks and Hank was like, it's good, it's a funny bit. And so I think he ended up making a video where he used the bit and then I ended up writing an essay about Diet Doctor Pepper and Canada Geese. And at the end of writing those essays, I was like, you know, this isn't very funny. And I kind of thought that it was gonna be a funny thing, but I like it and it interests me. And because I started out my career as a book reviewer,
在某种程度上，这让我感觉像是回到了家。因为尽管给比如霍乱按五星评分制进行评测显然有点棘手，但评论所固有的价值判断有一些东西让我感兴趣。我们在世界上用五星评分制评测一切，这是一件健康的事情吗？是的，我大概会给它两颗星。
it felt kind of like going home to me in a way. Because even though like it is obviously a little sticky to be reviewing, for instance, cholera on a five-star scale, there is something about the value judgmenting that's inherent to reviewing that interest may. Is it a healthy thing that we are reviewing everything on a five-star scale in the world? Yeah, I'd probably give it two stars. Yeah, I'd probably give it two stars. I definitely understand the urge to make simple qualitative judgments about experiences.
是的，我大概会给它两颗星。我绝对理解对经历做出简单定性判断的冲动。
But if you read one star Yelp reviews or you read one star Goodreads reviews, I think a lot of times there's some missing of nuance to put it generously. But also if you read a lot of five star Amazon reviews, there's a lot of missing of nuance. You know, sometimes I'll read reviews of my own books and I'll be like, we both know it's not that good. I wish it were. I wish it were the book that you're describing and I I'm so grateful that the book ended up in the hands of a reader so generous that they were able to make the book much better than the one I wrote.
但如果你阅读一星的Yelp评论，或者阅读一星的Goodreads评论，我认为很多时候，温和地说，是缺乏细微差别的。但如果你阅读很多五星的亚马逊评论，同样也缺乏很多细微差别的理解。你知道，有时我会读我自己的书的评论，然后我会想：我们俩都知道它没那么好。我希望它是。我希望它就是你所描述的那本书，我非常感激这本书最终落入了一位如此慷慨的读者手中，以至于他们能够让这本书变得比我写的那本好得多。
But I do feel like it kind of oversimplifies human experience. And it also gives us this constant urge to review everything we do. Like now it's difficult to have a meal and not think about it in the context of a recommend, don't recommend spectrum. And I don't know that I did that before the age of Yelp. Right.
但我的确觉得它有点过度简化了人类的经历。它也赋予了我们一种不断评测我们所做一切的冲动。就像现在，吃一顿饭却不从“推荐”或“不推荐”的范畴去思考它，已经变得很困难了。我不知道我在Yelp时代之前是否会这样做。
So when I was talking to my producer, an editor on the show, his name is Chris Baroubae, I was talking about which stories to highlight of the Anthemousine Reviewed. I said, I think I wanna do two, K paintings and talk about breakfast menu and pennies and pickly wiggly. And he's like, oh, so four. And I was like, no, no, no, those are two. So, is that how you view them?
对。所以当我跟我的制作人、节目编辑交谈时，他叫克里斯·巴鲁拜（Chris Baroubae），我谈到了要在《人类世观察》中突出哪些故事。我说，我想做两个，洞穴壁画和塔可钟早餐菜单，还有硬币和皮克利·维格利（Piggly Wiggly）。他说，哦，所以是四个。我说，不，不，不，那是两个。所以，你是这样看待它们的吗？
Yeah, I try to pair them in ways that make sense to me. So for instance when I was writing about the cave paintings at Lesco, I wanted to also write about the Taco Bell breakfast menu in part because it seems so different. It seems like a huge contrast. But also because I'm really fascinated by the way that people try to make an impact on the world, or they try to leave a trace of themselves, and I was fascinated by the way that Glenn Bell, the founder of Taco Bell, tried to do that, and by the way, the people who were painting the cave paintings at Lesco tried to do that. Yeah.
是的，我尽量以对我有意义的方式把它们配对。例如，当我写关于拉斯科洞穴壁画的文章时，我也想写关于塔可钟早餐菜单的文章，部分是因为它们看起来太不一样了。这似乎是一个巨大的对比。但也因为我真的很着迷于人们试图对世界产生影响的方式，或者他们试图留下自己痕迹的方式，我被塔可钟创始人格伦·贝尔试图做到这一点的方式，以及在拉斯科创作洞穴壁画的人试图做到这一点的方式所深深吸引。
I'm especially curious about the combination of Hawaiian pizza and viral meningitis. What made you choose that? Well, some would argue that they're both forms of suffering. I wrote the viral meningitis essay before I wrote the Hawaiian pizza essay. And at the end of the viral meningitis essay, I was thinking about how there are all these phenomena in human life that are really resistant to language. I think physical pain is the one that's perhaps most dramatically resistant to language. But for me, there's also something about taste that's resistant to language. But for me, there's also something about taste that's resistant to language.
我对夏威夷披萨和病毒性脑膜炎的结合特别好奇。是什么让你选择这个的？嗯，有些人会认为这两种都是痛苦的形式。我在写夏威夷披萨的文章之前写了病毒性脑膜炎的文章。在病毒性脑膜炎文章的结尾，我在思考人类生活中存在着所有这些对语言极其排斥的现象。我认为身体痛苦也许是受语言排斥最剧烈的现象。但对我和来说，还有一些关于味觉的东西是排斥语言的。
And one of the reasons we fight, I think, about Hawaiian pizza is because we almost cannot describe to each other how it tastes to us. And so I think some people say, well, Hawaiian pizza is amazing. And you're, you know're obviously wrong to hate it. And then the people who hate it are like, no, no, no, no, no, no, you don't understand how this tastes to me. And indeed, we don't. It's funny to me, one of my pet peeves with no basis whatsoever.
而且我认为，我们为夏威夷披萨争吵的原因之一，是因为我们几乎无法向对方描述它对我们而言是什么味道。所以我认为有些人会说，夏威夷披萨太棒了。而你，你知道，讨厌它是显然不对的。然后讨厌它的人就会说，不，不，不，不，你不明白这对我来说是什么味道。事实上，我们确实不明白。这对我来说很有趣，这是我的一个毫无根据的个人怪癖。
So it's not like I, you know, like I know I'm not necessarily right, is I hate when people use food words to describe other things. Like I hate it when somebody says that a like prose is delicious or something like that or sumptuous. Oh God, I'm using one to die. Yeah. So it goes the other way too. Like you can't use food words for other things. You can use them only for food and there's not enough of them. Yeah. Well, and even the food words that do exist, I don't know what they mean to someone else.
所以这并不是说我，你知道，就像我知道自己不一定是对的，我讨厌人们用食物的词汇来描述其他事情。比如我讨厌当有人说散文“delicious”（美味的）或者诸如此类的话，或者“sumptuous”（华丽的）。哦，天哪，我自己就用了一个。好吧，所以反过来也一样。就像你不能把食物的词汇用于其他事情一样。你只能将它们用于食物，而且食物的词汇还不够多。好吧，甚至那些确实存在的食物词汇，我也不知道它们对别人意味着什么。
I don't really know what sumptuous means. Anyone who says that Hawaiian pizza is delicious, my definition of delicious doesn't include Hawaiian pizza. And so I'm already lost. I have no way in. And they can say, oh, it's a wonderful mix of sweet and sour. And I understand what sweet and sour taste like, but that is not a wonderful mix of them to me.
我真的不知道“sumptuous”是什么意思。任何说夏威夷披萨美味的人，我对美味的定义不包括夏威夷披萨。所以我已经迷失了。我没有切入点。他们可以说，哦，这是酸甜的奇妙组合。我明白酸甜是什么味道，但对我来说，那不是它们的奇妙组合。
And so it's that personalization of experience and then the urge to share experience. Like we all desperately want other people to hear us and to hear our stories and to know what our feelings feel like. And they can't. The subjectures show is literally everything on Earth, kind of centered around when humans were the dominant species on Earth. Yeah, kind of.
所以这就是体验的个性化，然后是分享体验的冲动。就像我们都极度渴望别人倾听我们，倾听我们的故事，并知道我们的感受是什么感觉。但他们做不到。这个节目的主题实际上是地球上的万物，大致围绕着人类成为地球上主导物种的时期。是的，差不多。
And how do you then choose things to talk about? I choose what to write about partly based on listener suggestions. So listeners can write in and a lot of times they have really interesting ideas or ideas about why something is interesting that I hadn't thought about before. The Taco Bell Breakfast Menu is actually an example of that. I'd never thought about the Taco Bell Breakfast Menu until somebody wrote to ask me to review it. And then I was like, ah, this isn't that interesting.
那你又是如何选择讨论的事物的呢？我选择写什么部分是基于听众的建议。所以听众可以写信来，很多时候他们有非常有趣的想法，或者关于为什么某事很有趣的想法，这是我以前没有想过的。塔可钟早餐菜单其实就是一个例子。在有人写信让我评测它之前，我从未想过塔可钟的早餐菜单。然后我想，啊，这其实挺有意思的。
But then I fell way down the Glenville rabbit hole and it ended up reading Glenville's self-published commissioned biography. At the end of that, I was totally fascinated by why Taco Bell didn't have a breakfast menu for so long. But I also have a running list of topics that I care about and I'm interested in and that I think I have a way into. Whether it's a story I want to tell about my life or just a story I find really fascinating. Like the cave paintings that let's go, I learned about those, I think when I was in my 20s,
但我随后深入研究了格伦·贝尔的兔子洞，最终读了格伦·贝尔自费出版并委托撰写的传记。在那之后，我完全被为什么塔可钟这么长时间没有早餐菜单迷住了。但我也有一个我关心的、感兴趣的、并且我认为我有切入点的主题常备清单。无论是我想讲述的关于我生活的故事，还是我发现真的很引人入胜的故事。就像拉斯科的洞穴壁画，我了解到它们，我想是在我二十多岁的时候，
and I've just spent a lot of time thinking about them and reading about them, and so I felt ready to write that review. I mean, each of these reviews, it becomes a small memoir. Was that always your intention? Initially, my idea for the show was that I was gonna be separate from the reviews. I would be like an authority on everything.
我花了很多时间思考它们并阅读关于它们的内容，所以我觉得自己准备好写那篇评论了。我的意思是，这些评论中的每一篇，都变成了一部小型回忆录。这一直是你的初衷吗？最初，我对这个节目的想法是我将独立于评论之外。我将成为万物的权威。
I was gonna be an authority on Canada Geese and Diet Dr. Pepper and Cave Paintings and the Taco Bell breakfast menu and who I was didn't matter because I was the authority. And my wife read the first couple of essays and she said, you know, like, I don't buy you as an authoritative expert in the taste of Dr. Pepper. Like I just don't think,
我将成为关于大雁、健怡博士胡椒、洞穴壁画和塔可钟早餐菜单的权威，我是谁并不重要，因为我是权威。我妻子读了前几篇文章，她说，你知道，我不买账你作为博士胡椒口味的权威专家。就像我只是不认为，
I don't think you're a chemical engineer. I don't think that you're a professional taster. And I'm more interested in what your relationship is with this stuff. And that's when it became more memoir-y. And I do write about myself and I do write really personal things about myself, but I am very careful to protect the parts of me that I need to protect if that makes sense.
我不认为你是一个化学工程师。我不认为你是一个专业的品酒师。我对你与这些东西的关系更感兴趣。这就是它变得更有回忆录风格的时候。我确实写了我自己，我也确实写了关于我自己的非常个人的事情，但我非常小心地保护我需要保护的那部分自己，如果这说得通的话。
Because I wasn't always careful about that. And now I feel like I have to be. When I was younger, I wanted so badly to be known. I think what I wanted was to have people like me. For some reason, I wanted especially for people who didn't know me well to like me. It just seemed like that was such an incredibly desirable outcome to have strangers like you. When that versions of that started to happen to me, I almost immediately recognized that what I thought it would give me was not what it was giving me, because I never felt and
因为我以前并没有总是那么小心。现在我觉得我必须如此。当我更年轻的时候，我非常渴望被了解。我想我想要的是让人喜欢我。出于某种原因，我特别希望那些不怎么了解我的人喜欢我。让陌生人喜欢你，似乎是一个极其令人向往的结果。当这种情况的各种版本开始发生在我身上时，我几乎立刻意识到，我以为它会给我的东西并不是它正在给我的，因为我从来没有感觉到，而且
I still don't feel like strangers like me. I feel like they like a construction that is only tangentially related to me. I'm obsessed with this thing, Keanu Reeves said once. He said, I love Keanu Reeves a lot. Someday I might write a Keanu Reeves Anthropocene Reviewed review. But one time Keanu Reeves in an interview said, I'm Mickey Mouse. They don't know who's inside the suit. And when my work started to become more publicly known, that's how I felt. I didn't really feel like people liked me.
我依然不觉得陌生人喜欢我。我觉得他们喜欢的是一个只与我有着微弱联系的构建物。我对基努·里维斯（Keanu Reeves）曾经说过的一句话着迷。他说：我非常喜欢基努·里维斯。总有一天我可能会写一篇关于基努·里维斯的《人类世观察》评论。但有一次基努·里维斯在采访中说：“我是米老鼠。他们不知道面具里面是谁。”当我的作品开始广为人知时，我就是这种感觉。我不觉得人们真的喜欢我。
I felt like they liked Mickey Mouse. I was inside the suit. But I think the difference between Keanu Reeves and me is that Keanu Reeves knew who he was. He knew who was inside of the suit, but I kind of didn't. Do you find that when you, because you listened to a lot of podcasts and I assume before that or maybe, well, listen to a lot of public radio and stuff, when you find like a little tidbit of personal knowledge, like when Terry Gross reveals something to little about herself,
我觉得他们喜欢的是米老鼠。我在服装里面。但我想基努·里维斯和我的区别在于基努·里维斯知道他是谁。他知道服装里面是谁，但我有点不知道。你发现当你——因为你听了很多播客，我假设在那之前或者也许，嗯，听了很多公共广播之类的节目——当你发现一点点个人的知识，比如当特里·格罗斯（Terry Gross）透露一点关于她自己的小事时，
does it fill you with delight the way it fills me with delight? It does. And I, it does, especially when Terry Gross does it, you know, because I've, I've been listening to Terry Gross for like 25 years. So when Terry Gross shares even the smallest detail about her life, I am completely, oh, I love it. It's such a good feeling. I'm just like, oh, oh, well, that makes sense. That's always what I think to myself. Describes the piles of CDs on some, I'm like, oh, my God. She has towers and CDs and
它会像充满我那样，也充满你的喜悦吗？会的。而且我会，特别是当特里·格罗斯这样做的时候，你知道，因为我听特里·格罗斯的节目已经有25年左右了。所以当特里·格罗斯分享关于她生活的哪怕是最微小的细节时，我都完全——哦，我太喜欢了。这真是一种很好的感觉。我只是觉得，哦，哦，好吧，这就说得通了。我心里总是这么想。描述某人堆积如山的CD，我会想：天哪。她有成堆的CD，
I also CDs. Yes. Now I could picture the entire home. I mean, one of the things I've learned about you over time, and one of the things I think is fun is, and I don't know if I would anticipate this, I have from reading your books and other things and from blog brothers, but you love sports. Or certain sports. I mean, because my growing up experience was that the people who love sports were the people who hated me. I have the same... that the people who love sports were the people who hated me. I... Yeah, same.
我也有CD。是的。现在我可以想象出整个家了。我的意思是，随着时间的推移，我了解你的一点是，我认为有趣的一件事是——我不知道我是否会预料到这一点——我从读你的书和其他东西以及从“博客兄弟”（vlogbrothers）那里知道，你喜欢体育运动。或者某些体育运动。我的意思是，因为我的成长经历是，喜欢体育运动的人正是那些讨厌我的人。我有同样的……喜欢体育运动的人就是那些讨厌我的人。我……是的，一样。
That these are not linked traits, but you've decoupled them for me in these ways that I found really profound. And so, you talk about penalty shootouts, or I know your love of AFC, Wimbledon, and then in the 500, which is like, which kind of floored me as a subject, the fact that you love the Indianapolis 500, I think that you love the Indianapolis 500. I think that you could assemble the parts of your character and I could construct a version of you that would hate the Indianapolis 500. Well, yeah, and a past me did hate the Indianapolis 500 and a past me did hate sports. There's a lot of my first novel looking for Alaska that's something like
这些不是联系在一起的特质，但你以我发现非常深刻的方式为我将它们解耦了。所以，你谈论点球大战，或者我知道你对温布尔登AFC（AFC Wimbledon）的热爱，然后在印地500（Indianapolis 500），作为一个主题简直把我惊呆了，你竟然喜欢印地500赛车，我认为你喜欢印地500赛车。我想你可以拼凑出你性格的各个部分，而我可以构建出一个会讨厌印地500赛车的你。嗯，是的，过去的我也确实讨厌印地500赛车，过去的我也确实讨厌体育运动。我的第一部小说《寻找阿拉斯加》中有很多内容类似于：
I hate sports and I hate people who play or support or Participate in any way in the sports industrial complex and that was taken right out of my high school self I I would watch people care about sports and I would just think to myself This is actually the dumbest thing that you can do with what Mary Oliver called your one wild and precious life. Like this is the worst possible way for you to use your resources. If I've learned anything in adulthood, it's not to judge anyone else, West you, become
我讨厌体育运动，我讨厌那些参与、支持或以任何方式参与体育产业复合体的人，这直接取自我高中时的自我。我会看着人们关心体育运动，然后我心里就会想：这实际上是你用玛丽·奥利弗（Mary Oliver）所谓的“你那狂野而宝贵的人生”能做的最愚蠢的事情。这就像是你使用资源的可能最糟糕的方式。如果我在成年后学到了什么，那就是不要评判任何人，以免你变成
them. In the fullness of time, you will become all of the people that you claim to revile. I think what I love about sports is actually the same thing I love about going to church, which is not much to do with the ostensible topic at hand, but instead the pleasure and joy that comes from a bunch of people who otherwise might not have a lot in common, orienting their love in the same direction. And I think there is a lot of value in that. And I think what I like about sports is the community aspect of it, which is why I enjoy the Indy 500 so much because it's this huge gathering of all kinds of human beings.
他们。随着时间的推移，你将成为所有你声称痛恨的人。我想我喜欢体育运动的原因其实和我喜欢去教堂的原因是一样的，这与手头表面的话题没有太大关系，而是来自于一群原本可能没有太多共同点的人，将他们的爱朝向同一个方向时所产生的快乐和喜悦。我认为这里面有很多价值。而且我认为我喜欢体育运动的是它的社群属性，这就是为什么我如此享受印地500，因为它是一场各种人类的巨大聚会。
And the sport, to say that it's secondary, would be an overstatement. I mean, there's no place in the Indianapolis 500 seating where you can see all of the Indian apolis 500 seating, where you can see all of the Indianapolis 500. So it can't possibly be about the sport because you literally can't see the sport from inside the stadium. It has to be about something else. And I think what it's about is tradition
要说这项运动是次要的，那都算是轻描淡写。我的意思是，印第安纳波利斯500赛车场里根本没有哪个位置能让你看清整个印第安纳波利斯500赛车比赛，让你看清全部的印第安纳波利斯500。所以这绝对不可能是关于这项运动本身的，因为你字面意义上就无法从赛场内部看到这项运动。它一定关乎别的东西。我认为它关乎的是传统
and shared experience and being in a community. I think really like in the end, sports are about being together. Mm-hmm. I found in my life, and I sense this in your life, is that you spent a good section of the being in your life being defined by the things you hated, and then you took a hard pivot,
以及共同的经历和身处一个社群之中。我想最终，体育运动其实就是为了聚在一起。嗯。我在我的生活中发现，而且我也从你的生活中感觉得到，你人生中的很大一部分时间，都是由你所厌恶的事物来定义的，然后你来了个急转弯，
enjoying being defined more by the things you loved. Do you know why and how that happened in both you and I? I do not know. When I was a teenager, if you'd asked me to say 10 things about myself, I would have told you 10 things that I hated. I would have told you about what I was opposed to, I would have told you about what I thought was stupid and embarrassing and ridiculous about the human experience. I would have told you like how deeply I reviled the Spice Girls. Who by the way made good pop music. And I think I got fed up with it.
转变为更多地由你所热爱的事物来定义自己。你知道为什么以及这是怎么发生在你我身上的吗？我不知道。当我还是个十几岁的时候，如果你让我说出关于自己的10件事，我会告诉你10件我讨厌的事。我会告诉你我反对什么，我会告诉你我认为人类经历中哪些东西是愚蠢的、尴尬的、荒谬的。我会告诉你我是多么深深地痛恨辣妹组合。顺便说一句，她们创作了很好的流行音乐。我想我是受够了这一切。
I got fed up with irony. I got fed up with irony. I got fed up with sarcasm. I got fed up with this urge to create distance between myself and emotion. I wanted to be cool and I thought that to be cool was to be distant. And then I stopped wanting to be cool because to be cool is to be a form of cold. And I don't want to be distant from emotional experience. I think the risk of that is that it
我受够了讽刺。我受够了讽刺。我受够了挖苦。我受够了这种试图在自己和情感之间制造距离的冲动。我曾经想变得冷酷，我以为冷酷就是保持距离。然后我不再渴望冷酷了，因为冷酷本身就是一种冰冷。我不想与情感体验保持距离。我认为这样做的风险在于，它
may make you into a sentimentalist, it may make you into some sort of like cheesy version of yourself. For me, if that's the cost of having unironized emotional experiences, it's worth the cost. It took me a long time to be okay with that urge within me. I just think that ironic detachment is the single most overrated characteristic in a human being.
可能会把你变成一个多愁善感的人，可能会把你变成某种流于俗套的自己。对我来说，如果这就是获得未经讽刺滤镜的情感体验所付出的代价，那完全值得。我花了很长时间才接受内心的这种冲动。我只是觉得，讽刺性的抽离是人类身上被高估得最厉害的特征。
I like emotion, I like to feel things, I like to feel them intensely, and I like to be able to ask big questions without creating a lot of distance between myself and the questions. Yeah. If you were to review other things in your life besides sports and the spice scrolls, where are some of the things that had the most change from one star or zero stars to five stars in your life? Oh, that's interesting. Oh, I mean, the biggest one is marriage.
我喜欢情感，我喜欢去感受事物，我喜欢强烈地去感受它们，而且我喜欢能够在不与这些问题拉开太大距离的情况下提出宏大的问题。是的。如果你回顾一下生活中除了体育和辣妹组合之外的其他事物，有哪些事情在你的生活中发生了最大的改变，从一星或零星变成了五星？哦，这很有趣。哦，我是说，最大的改变是婚姻。
I mean, my 17 year old self thought that marriage was the stupidest institution that humans had ever conceived of. And I love being married. stupidest institution that humans had ever conceived of. And I love being married. That guy was crazy. I really, really, really love being married. I think the institution of marriage has gotten a lot better since I was a kid. It's gotten a lot more inclusive.
我是说，我17岁的时候认为婚姻是人类有史以来构想出的最愚蠢的制度。而我热爱婚姻。人类有史以来构想出的最愚蠢的制度。而我热爱婚姻。当年的那个我真是疯了。我真的、真的、真的很热爱婚姻。我认为自从我小时候起，婚姻制度已经变得好多了。它变得更加包容了。
It hasn't gone all the way to where it needs to be throughout the world, but I think that's one. In general, pop music, I was very dismissive of pop music when I was younger, and now I listen to a lot of pop songs. Like, you know that song, Old Town Road by Will Nas X. It's been mentioned a few times, but I actually haven't heard it, but I've heard good things. I genuinely recommend that you listen to it. It's a good song. Is it good enough to have my kids play it 40 or 50 times a day
它还没有在全世界范围内完全达到应有的地步，但我认为这是一个改变。总的来说，流行音乐，我年轻时对流行音乐非常不屑一顾，而现在我听很多流行歌曲。就像，你知道那首歌吗，纳斯小子（Lil Nas X）的《老镇路》（Old Town Road）。这首歌已经被提到好几次了，但我其实还没听过，不过我听说评价很好。我真心推荐你听听。这是一首好歌曲。它足够好到让我的孩子一天放上40或50遍吗？
every day? No, but it's very good. I've also gone from one star to five stars on genre fiction, like mystery novels, romance novels. I love a good romance novel. I used to think that, oh, they all end the same way and they're so cheesy and they're just wish fulfillment. Well, shut up. Like what's wrong with wish fulfillment? Like, when did we become opposed to fulfilling
每天都放？不，但它非常不错。我对类型文学也从一星改到了五星，比如悬疑小说、言情小说。我喜欢一本好的言情小说。我过去认为，哦，它们的结局都一样，而且太俗气了，纯粹是愿望实现。好吧，闭嘴吧。愿望实现有什么错？就像，我们是从什么时候开始反对实现
wishes? I can go on, man. I've, I mean, if anything, like I'm probably now too critical of my high school self, because that means that like in the next 10 years I'm going to become my high school self again so that I have to like cease being critical toward him. Right. The thing about my high school self, and I don't know if you are like this, is that I was very dismissive of pop culture, but I was also dismissive of large swaths of high culture that my hatred of them is just super embarrassing. Like the quintessential example from my life
愿望的呢？我还可以继续说下去，老兄。我，我是说，如果说有什么不同的话，那就是我现在可能对高中时的自己过于批判了，因为这意味着在接下来的10年里，我将再次变成高中时的那个自己，以至于我不得不停止对他的批判。没错。关于我高中时的那个自己，我不知道你是不是也这样，我对流行文化很不屑一顾，但我也对庞大的高级文化群体不屑一顾，我对它们的厌恶现在想来简直太尴尬了。比如我生活中的典型例子
is that when I was a teenager, I hated the great Gatsby. I thought it was. I wrote a paper that I still have, that I should destroy before I die, but I wrote a paper that I still have that I should destroy before I die, but I wrote a paper that I still have in which I called the great Gatsby a bunch of rich Yankees with Yankee problems I grew up in Alabama for context and Like the lack of understanding in that characterization of the great Gatsby is a reminder that like
就是当我还是个青少年时，我讨厌《了不起的盖茨比》。我以为它是。我写过一篇论文，我现在还留着，虽然我应该在我死前把它销毁，但我写过一篇论文，我现在还留着，虽然我应该在我死前把它销毁，但我写过一篇论文，在其中我把《了不起的盖茨比》称为一群带着北方佬问题的富裕北方佬——为了提供背景，我在阿拉巴马州长大——那种对《了不起的盖茨比》的性格刻画缺乏理解，这提醒我们，
one star goodreads reviews are not necessarily reflective of the quality of a work. That's right. Also, like I'm so glad that my high school self did not have access to Twitter because if he had, like I would still be living with that and people would be like, you know, this guy hates the great Gatsby. And oh God, thank you for making me born in 1977. When you see the things you make interacting with the world and the image I have in my mind is Ant-Man reading the Fault in Our Stars in Bedtime. Which was a moment of delight for me. stars in bedc
古德里reads网站上一星的好评并不一定能反映作品的质量。没错。还有，我太庆幸我高中时没有用推特了，因为如果我有的话，我到现在还得承受那些言论，人们会说，你知道的，这家伙讨厌《了不起的盖茨比》。哦，天哪，谢谢你让我生于1977年。当你看到你创作的事物与世界互动时，我脑海中浮现的画面是《蚁人》在睡前阅读《无比美妙的痛苦》。这对我来说是一个欣喜的时刻。
which was a moment of delight for me. But when you see your things that you make interacting with the culture of the world, how does it make you feel? When it's things like Ant-Man reading the fault in their stars, it's just like a wonderful, delightful, unexpected
对我来说这是一个欣喜的时刻。但当你看到你创作的东西与世界的文化互动时，这让你有什么感觉？当看到像《蚁人》在读《无比美妙的痛苦》这样的事情时，那种感觉就像是一个奇妙的、令人愉快的、意想不到的
moment. And that one in particular was fun because I was with my son in the movie theater. And he like said out loud, dad, that's your book. And I was like, I know, I know. And he was like, did you know that was gonna happen? And I was like, no, how could I have known? It's not like they called me to clear it.
时刻。而那个时刻特别有趣，因为我和我儿子当时在电影院里。他甚至大声说出来：“爸爸，那是你的书。”然后我说：“我知道，我知道。”接着他问：“你知道会发生这种事吗？”我说：“不，我怎么可能知道？又不是他们打电话向我核实过。”
I would have thought they called you to clear it. Actually. They didn't. Or at least if they did, they clear it. Actually. They didn't. Or at least if they did, they didn't call me, they called someone else. But to be honest, it can get overwhelming. It can get a little scary somehow, or yeah, I don't know how to say it except for scary.
我本以为他们会打电话向你核实呢。实际上。他们没有。或者至少如果他们核实了。实际上。他们没有。或者至少如果他们核实了，他们没有打电话给我，而是打了给别人。但说实话，这确实会让人感到不知所措。不知为何，这会让人觉得有点吓人，或者，是的，除了“吓人”我不知道该怎么形容。
I can remember right when the Fallen R. Stars movie came out because it was for a few weeks like fairly close to the center of US pop culture. Like, A, people were saying things about it that I thought were really kind of unfair. In the way that we always are judging popular cultural phenomena, you know, like, I've always felt like if something becomes very popular,
我还记得《无比美妙的痛苦》电影刚上映的时候，因为在几个星期里它相当于是美国流行文化的中心。比如说，A，人们对它发表的一些看法我觉得非常不公平。就像我们对流行文化现象进行评判时的常态一样，你知道的，我一直觉得如果某样东西变得非常受欢迎，
there must be something at least a little bit wrong with it. It was weird and uncomfortable to be in that position. But also things like having a Saturday night live sketch or something made out of your work, that parodies your work. In a way, it's fun. And I thought the sketch that they made was very funny. But yeah, it was hard just not to feel really overwhelmed by it in a little almost an urge to shut down.
它多多少少一定有点问题。处于那种位置感觉既诡异又别扭。但也有些事情，比如《周六夜现场》制作了关于你的作品的喜剧小品，恶搞了你的作品。从某种程度上讲，这很有趣。而且我觉得他们制作的小品非常搞笑。但说实话，要想不为此感到彻底不知所措、甚至几乎产生一种想要关闭自我的冲动，确实很难。
I don't think it's a coincidence that I didn't write a novel for like six years after that book came out. I've been interviewed on TV just only a couple of times, like a handful of times, and I'm never seen any of them. I just can't. I don't wanna know. I don't wanna know if I felt bad about it.
那本书出版后的大约六年里我都没有写小说，这绝不是巧合。我只在电视上接受过几次采访，寥寥几次，而且我从来没看过去任何一个。我就是看不了。我不想知道。我不想知道自己是不是对此感觉很糟糕。
I don't wanna know. I just don't wanna know. Yeah. It's hard not to, I mean, obviously these are like incredibly rarefied problems that I am extremely grateful to have. You know, like I definitely had a moment there where I could have chosen a path that I didn't choose.
我不想知道。我就是不想知道。是的。很难不去——我的意思是，很显然这些都是极其罕见的问题，对此我极其感激。你知道的，在那里面我绝对有过这样一个时刻，我可以选择一条我没有选择的路。
Like we could have moved to LA or New York and gotten lots of work and there were lots of opportunities. What I kind of chose to do was to come back here to Indianapolis and to work on making crash scores. Our educational video series better and to work on the stuff that I wanted to work on. That was both lower profile, but also that I had more control over. Because I think part of what was so disorienting about that experience was losing some control over both my work and on some level over myself, or at least like the way that myself was being portrayed
比如我们可以搬到洛杉矶或纽约，接很多工作，那里有很多机会。而我选择做的事情是回到印第安纳波利斯这里，致力于把“速成课程”（Crash Course）这个教育视频系列做得更好，并去做那些我想做的事情。这既是一个低调一些的项目，但也是一个我拥有更多控制权的项目。因为我认为那段经历之所以让人如此不知所措，部分原因在于我失去了一些对自己的作品的控制，并在某种程度上失去了对自己的控制，或者至少是失去了对自己被描绘和想象的方式的控制
and imagined. I'm really like interested in you deciding to sort of pull back and do crash course and stuff instead of doing punch up on some script or something. You know, it's not because you have disdain for those things. It's just that, no, not at all. You know, it's just kind of like, well, I got my thing. My thing's great. Can't tell you my favorite joke. I'm sure you've heard this joke, but you've never heard me do it. So a moth walks into a podiatrist's office.
我真的很感兴趣你决定退居幕后，去做“速成课程”之类的事情，而不是去给某个剧本润色。你知道的，这并不是因为你对那些事情不屑一顾。这只是因为，不，完全不是。你知道的，这更像是，好吧，我有我自己的东西。我的东西很棒。我不能告诉你我最喜欢的笑话。我确信你听过这个笑话，但你肯定没听过我讲它。所以，有一只蛾子走进了足病医生的诊所。
Do you know this joke? I don't know if I, I don't know it from that setup. All right, then you don't know the joke. A moth walks into a podiatrist's office and the podiatrist says, what seems to be the problem of a moth and the moth says, oh, Doc, if only there were one problem. I mean, you know, my wife doesn't love me anymore.
你知道这个笑话吗？我不知道我是不是——我从这个开场白认不出它。好吧，那你确实不知道这个笑话。一只蛾子走进了足病医生的诊所，足病医生问：“蛾子先生，请问有什么问题吗？”蛾子说：“噢，医生，如果只有一个问题就好了。我的意思是，你懂的，我妻子不再爱我了。
It's not just that she doesn't love me. I don't even remember a time when she did love me. My daughter has married a man who my despise and who despises me. My son is a wretched failure. And to be honest, when I look at him, all I see is a reflection of my own failures. I just don't know how to go on, Doc.
不仅仅是她不爱我了。我甚至记不起她爱过我的时候了。我女儿嫁了一个我鄙视而且也鄙视我的男人。我儿子是个一事无成的废物。老实说，当我看着他时，我看到的只是我自己失败的倒影。医生，我真不知道该怎么继续活下去。
I don't know. I don't know. You know? And the podiatrist says, oh, well, those seems like like very serious problems, moth, but I'm a podiatrist. What brought you here today? And the moth says, Oh, the light was on. I love that joke. Because like the joke is that mods are stupid and they just go where the light is on. But the other thing about the joke is that almost all the time humans don't go where the light is on. And I really try in my own life thinking hard about, you know, am I doing this because I want to do it?
我不知道。我不知道。你知道吗？足病医生说：“噢，好吧，蛾子，这些听起来像是非常严重的问题，但我是一名足病医生。你今天为什么来这里呢？”蛾子说：“哦，因为灯亮着。”我喜欢这个笑话。因为这个笑话的讽刺之处在于，蛾子很愚蠢，它们只会飞向灯亮的地方。但关于这个笑话的另一层含义是，几乎在所有时候，人类都不会去灯亮的地方。而在我自己的生活中，我真的在努力认真思考，你知道的，我做这件事是因为我想做，
Or am I doing this because of the light is on? Yeah. So how would you rate our conversation on a five star scale? I mean, from my side, four and a half stars, but I'm more worried about how you would rate it. Now I'm nervous. I could be giddy in the moment, but I'm thinking solid five stars. I don't mean to be one of those Amazon reviews
还是因为灯亮着？那么你会给我们的对话打几分，五星制？我的意思是，站在我的角度，四星半，但我更担心你会怎么打分。现在我开始紧张了。我当下可能会有点忘形，但我觉得稳稳的五星。我可不是那种让你心存怀疑的亚马逊评论区里的人
that you're skeptical of. I really truly appreciate it. It's been great to talk to you. After the break, John Green reviews the pegley wiggly, and he just lays into the penny. Honestly, it's the angriest I've ever heard him. More Anthropocene Reviewed on 99% Invisible. Hello and welcome to the Anthropocene Reviewed, a podcast where we review different facets of the Human-Centered Planet on a 5-star scale. My name is John Green and today I'll be reviewing pennies, an ostensible
我真的是由衷地感激。和你聊天太棒了。休息过后，约翰·格林将点评皮格利·维格利（Piggly Wiggly）超市，而且他毫不留情地痛批了硬分币。老实说，这是我听过他最生气的一次。更多“人类世纪实”节目，敬请收听99%隐形。你好，欢迎收听“人类世纪实”，这是一个以五星制评测人类中心星球各个方面的播客。我是约翰·格林，今天我将评测硬分币——一种表面上存在于美国的
form of currency here in the United States, and the grocery store chain, Piggly Wiggly. Let's begin with the American penny, which is worth $1.100 of a US dollar and is almost as old as the nation itself. The first US penny was minted in 1793. It was made of copper, weighed about half an ounce, and was the size of a contemporary one dollar coin, which come to think of it as a useless comparison since nobody uses one dollar coins even though their adoption would save the United States hundreds of millions of dollars per year. But we're not here to review the two-star one dollar bill.
货币形式，以及杂货店连锁店皮格利·维格利。让我们从美国硬分币开始说起，它的价值相当于1美元的百分之一，历史几乎和这个国家本身一样悠久。第一枚美国硬分币铸造于1793年。它由铜制成，重约半盎司，大小与当代的一美元硬币相当，仔细想想，这是一个毫无用处的比较，因为根本没有人使用一美元硬币，尽管推广使用一美元硬币每年可以为美国节省数亿美元。不过我们今天不是来评测两星的一美元纸币的。
We're here to review the penny, which since 1909 has featured the profiled face of US President Abraham Lincoln. The penny was actually the first US money to be stamped with a president's face. Many of the U.S. founders, including George Washington, felt it would be too monarchical to mint coins featuring U.S. leaders. In fact, the U.S. Mint Act of 1792 explicitly stated that one side of copper coins should state the denomination, and the other side should have a, quote, impression emblematic of liberty. Today's pennies weigh about a fifth of what the 18th century ones did, and while they're still coated in copper, pennies are now over 97% zinc, which
我们是来评测硬分币的，自1909年以来，硬分币的正面一直是美国总统亚伯拉罕·林肯的侧面头像。硬分币实际上是第一种印有总统头像的美国货币。许多美国建国先贤，包括乔治·华盛顿，曾认为铸造印有美国领导人头像的硬币未免带有君主制的色彩。事实上，1792年的美国铸币法案明确规定，铜币的一面应标明面值，而另一面应该有一个，引述：“象征自由的图案”。今天的硬分币重量约为18世纪硬分币的五分之一，虽然它们表面仍然镀铜，但现在的硬分币97%以上都是锌，
is cheaper than copper. But even so, every one cent coin minted in the United States costs costs 1.82 cents to create. Last year, the US Mint lost $69 million minting pennies. That would be annoying, but forgivable if pennies served a purpose in our economy, but they don't. Money is supposed to facilitate the exchange of goods and services, which pennies manifestly fail to do. You can't use them in vending machines or parking meters, and if you attempt to use them to purchase goods or services, you will often be met with resistance and for good reason. I mean, it requires over two pounds of pennies around a kilogram to purchase a single gallon of gasoline.
锌比铜便宜。即便如此，在美国铸造的每一枚一分钱硬币，其生产成本都要达到1.82美分。去年，美国铸币局在铸造硬分币上亏损了6900万美元。如果硬分币在我们的经济中能发挥某种作用，这种亏损虽然烦人但还可以原谅，但它们并没有。货币本应用来促进商品和服务的交换，而硬分币显然没有做到这一点。你不能在自动售货机或停车收费表里使用它们，如果你试图用它们来购买商品或服务，你通常会遭到抗拒，而且这是有充分理由的。我的意思是，仅仅买一加仑汽油就需要两磅多的硬分币（大约一公斤）。
And yet every year, the US Mint makes more pennies than all other coins combined, not because we use them so often to buy things, but because we don't use them, we store them in jars or leave them in the terrifying netherworld of our car's center consoles, and we throw them away by the million, because pennies do not work as currency. Now, there are many arguments in favor of the continued production of the penny. I just don't find any of them convincing. Some argue, for instance, that in a penniless world, prices might go up, and that those price increases would disproportionately affect the poor, who are more likely to use cash in transactions. But in fact, eliminating the penny would not increase prices.
然而每年，美国铸币局生产的硬分币数量仍然超过所有其他硬币的总和，不是因为我们经常用它们买东西，而是因为我们不用它们，我们把它们存放在罐子里，或者把它们扔进汽车中控台那个可怕的深渊里，我们成百万地把它们扔掉，因为硬分币根本无法作为货币发挥作用。现在，有许多赞成继续生产硬分币的论点。只是我觉得这些论点全无说服力。例如，有人认为，在一个没有硬分币的世界里，物价可能会上涨，而这种物价上涨会对穷人造成不成比例的影响，因为穷人在交易中更有可能使用现金。但事实上，取消硬分币并不会导致物价上涨。
We know this because many nations have already retired their penny equivalence without any problems from the Netherlands to New Zealand. We would simply begin rounding prices to the nearest tenth of a dollar instead of the nearest hundredth of a dollar, assuming we had the common sense to also eliminate our five cent coins, each of which cost 6.2 cents to mint. If anything, this system would benefit those who use cash because they would spend the same amount of money, but no longer have to deal with pennies, which are so easy to receive as change and so difficult to spend.
我们之所以知道这一点，是因为许多国家已经废除了与其硬分币等值的货币，且没有引发任何问题，从荷兰到新西兰都是如此。我们只需将价格四舍五入到十分之一美元，而不是百分之一美元即可，前提是我们有足够的常识把五分硬币也废除了——铸造每一枚五分硬币的成本高达6.2美分。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是这个系统实际上会使使用现金的人受益，因为他们花掉的钱是一样的，却再也不用处理那些找零时极易收到、花出去却极其艰难的硬分币了。
People often resort to cashing out their small denomination coins via coin counting machines like CoinStar, which charge an astonishing 12% fee for the privilege of turning your pennies and nickels into money you can actually spend. Other defenses of the penny that it honors Lincoln or that it somehow limits inflation are just absurd. None of the countries that have eliminated one cent coins has seen a corresponding rise in inflation. And why would Abraham Lincoln want to be the face of a coin that is worth negative $69 million per year? The whole thing is ridiculous. But then again, righteous indignation at the ongoing existence of the penny is also ridiculous. $69 million represents a tiny fraction of the US federal
人们经常求助于使用点币机（如CoinStar）将小面额硬币兑换成现金，而这些机器要收取惊人的12%的手续费，只为了把你的硬分币和五分镍币变成你可以真正花出去的钱。对硬分币的其他辩护——比如它是在纪念林肯，或者它在某种程度上限制了通货膨胀——简直荒谬绝伦。没有哪个废除了一分钱硬币的国家出现过相应的通货膨胀率上升。再说了，亚伯拉罕·林肯怎么会愿意成为一种每年带来负6900万美元价值的硬币上的头像呢？整件事简直荒唐透顶。但话又说回来，对硬分币持续存在所表现出的义愤填膺同样也是荒谬的。6900万美元只占美国联邦预算的极小一部分，
budget, like we spend about $68 million on the military per hour. We have much bigger problems than the penny. The United States is one of the only nations that has seen life expectancy decline in the past two years, despite the fact that we spend more on healthcare than any other country. Our massive economic inequality is inhibiting economic growth and limiting opportunity. Our political systems are far too profoundly influenced by moneyed interests. political systems are far too profoundly influenced by moneyed interests, and eliminating the penny will fix none of that. But our failure to bid farewell to the penny seems to me indicative of a larger political failure.
比如我们在军事上每小时就要花掉大约6800万美元。我们面临的问题比硬分币重大得多。美国是过去两年中人均预期寿命出现下降的少数几个国家之一，尽管我们在医疗保健上的花费比世界上任何其他国家都多。我们巨大的经济不平等正在阻碍经济增长并限制机会。我们的政治体制受到金钱利益的深刻影响。政治体制受到金钱利益的深刻影响，而取消硬分币根本无法解决这些问题。但我们未能与硬分币道别，在我看来，这恰恰折射出了更大的政治失灵。
We cannot accomplish simple and obvious things, because there is nothing to be gained politically by accomplishing them. Almost all of our political discourse is focused on issues that can score points and energize supporters. Should this Supreme Court nominee be approved as an issue that can drive donations? Should the penny be eliminated is not? In part, because it's not very important, and in part, because it's not very important, and in part because it's not very divisive. There is, of course, nothing surprising about the fact that Congress can't find the
我们无法完成简单而显而易见的事情，因为在政治上完成这些事情毫无收益可言。我们几乎所有的政治话语都集中在那些能够赢得选票并激发支持者热情的议题上。这个最高法院提名人是否应该通过，是一个能够拉动捐款的议题；而硬分币是否应该被取消，则不是。部分原因在于它不是很重要，部分原因在于它不是很重要，部分原因在于它并不具有很大的争议性。当然，国会找不到
political will to eliminate pennies. I mean, if Congress were drowning, it would struggle to pass the throw Congress something that floats act. The U.S. political system is complex by design. Change is supposed to be difficult to enact. But I'm not convinced it should be this difficult. In 1857, the United States was only a few years away from a civil war. I know 160 years ago seems like ancient history, but consider this, two of the grandfathers of my grandfathers fought in that war, on opposite sides. I know history can feel settled,
取消硬分币的政治意愿，这并不令人意外。我的意思是，如果国会溺水了，它连通过一项“向国会扔个救生圈法案”都会费劲。美国的政治体制在设计上就是复杂的。变革本来就很难推行。但我并不确信它应该这么难。1857年，美国距离内战爆发仅剩几年时间。我知道160年前看起来像是上古历史，但想想看，我的祖父的祖父辈里有两个人曾在那场战争中浴血奋战，而且分属敌对双方。我知道历史可能会让人觉得已经尘埃落定，
but we, the results of history, are anything but settled. So right, it's 1857. Political divisions over slavery are such that a year earlier, an abolitionist senator named Charles Sumner had been beaten with a cane nearly to death in the chamber of the United States Senate by a pro-slavery congressman named Preston Brooks, who by the way would go on to be reelected by his constituents. And yet even then, as the House divided against itself was learning that it could not stand, the United States Congress passed the coinage act of 1857 into law. Among other things, the act eliminated the half penny, which had become too small a monetary sum to be worth
但我们，这些历史的结果，却远未尘埃落定。所以没错，那是1857年。围绕奴隶制的政治分歧如此之剧烈，以至于就在前一年，一位名叫查尔斯·萨姆纳（Charles Sumner）的废奴主义参议员在美国参议院议事大厅里，被一位名叫普雷斯顿·布鲁克斯（Preston Brooks）的亲奴隶制众议员用手杖殴打得差点丧命，顺便说一句，这位布鲁克斯后来还被他的选民重新选入了国会。然而即便在那个时候，正当这个内部分裂之家认识到自己无法存续下去的时候，美国国会还是通过了1857年铸币法案。除其他事项外，该法案废除了半分币，因为当时的半分币面额太小，已经不值得
minting. At the time, the half penny was worth about 12 cents in today's money. To me, the ongoing existence of the penny symbolizes not only our inability to find common ground, but also our inability to acknowledge the places where common ground already exists. In fact, I think the only vaguely convincing case one can make for the penny is that as a nation, we all share it. No matter where you're from, or what news outlet you rely upon, no matter your age or race or gender, we can all agree that the continued minting of the American
铸造了。在当时，半分币的价值相当于今天货币的大约12美分。在我看来，硬分币的持续存在不仅象征着我们无法找到共同立场，更象征着我们无法承认那些已经存在共同立场的地方。事实上，我认为关于硬分币唯一勉强算得上具有说服力的论点是，作为一个国家，我们共同拥有它。无论你来自哪里，无论你依赖哪家新闻媒体，无论你的年龄、种族或性别如何，我们都可以一致同意，继续铸造美国
penny is an absolute abomination. Maybe it's worth $69 million a year to have something that we can all dislike together. And anyway, there is something kind of American about putting our best president on our worst coin. I give the penny one and a half stars. I give the penny one and a half stars. I give the penny one and a half stars. I give the penny one and a half stars. I give the penny one and a half stars.
硬分币绝对是一个令人发指的祸害。也许为了能有一个让我们大家共同厌恶的东西，每年花上6900万美元也是值得的。不管怎样，把我们最好的总统印在我们最烂的硬币上，本身就有一种某种美国式的风味。我给硬分币打一个半星。我给硬分币打一个半星。我给硬分币打一个半星。我给硬分币打一个半星。我给硬分币打一个半星。
I give the penny one and a half stars. In 1920, my maternal grandmother's father was working at a grocery store in a tiny town in western Tennessee. Like all U.S. grocery stores at the beginning of the 20th century, this one was full service. You walked in with a list of items you needed, and then the grocer, perhaps my great-grandfather, would gather those items. They'd weigh the flour, or cornmeal, or butter, or tomatoes, wrap everything up for you,
我给硬分币打一个半星。1920年，我外祖母的父亲在田纳西州西部一个小镇的一家杂货店里工作。就像20世纪初所有的美国杂货店一样，这家店提供全套服务。你拿着需要的物品清单走进去，然后杂货商——也许就是我的曾祖父——会把这些东西收集起来。他们会称好面粉、玉米面、黄油或西红柿的重量，把所有东西为你打包好，
and then charge it to your account. You'd either wait for the clerk to finish your shopping for you, or for a small fee you'd have your order delivered to your house later in the day. Like almost all grocery stores at the time, my great-grandfather's store also allowed customers to purchase food on credit, which the customer would then, usually, pay back over time. That store was supposed to be my great-grandfather's ticket out of poverty, but it didn't work out that way.
然后记在你的账上。你要么等着店员为你完成采购，要么支付一小笔费用，在当天晚些时候把订单送到你家里。就像当时几乎所有的杂货店一样，我曾祖父的店也允许顾客赊购食品，顾客通常会在日后分期偿还。这家店本该是我曾祖父摆脱贫困的入场券，但事情并没有按预想的那样发展。
Instead, the store closed, thanks in part to the self-service grocery revolution launched by Clarence Saunders. Saunders was the self-educated child of impoverished sharecroppers. He eventually found his way to the grocery business in Memphis, Tennessee. He was 35 when he developed the concept for a grocery store that would have no clerks or counters, but instead a labyrinth of aisles that customers would walk themselves, choosing their own food, and placing it in their own shopping baskets. Prices at Saunders' self-service grocery would be lower because his stores would employ
相反，由于克拉伦斯·桑德斯（Clarence Saunders）发起的自助杂货革命，这家店倒闭了。桑德斯是贫困佃农抚养长大、靠自学成才的孩子。他最终在田纳西州孟菲斯市涉足了杂货业。当他构思出一种既没有店员也没有柜台、只有顾客自己走进去挑选食物并放入自己的购物篮的迷宫般通道的杂货店概念时，他35岁。桑德斯的自助杂货店价格会更低，因为他的店铺雇佣的
fewer clerks and also because he wouldn't offer customers credit but instead expect immediate payment. The prices would also be clear and transparent. For the first time, every item in a grocery store would be marked with a price, so customers would no longer fear being overcharged by unscrupulous grocers. Saunders called his grocery store, Piggly Wiggly. Why? Nobody knows. When asked where the name came from, Saunders once answered that it arrived from out of chaos and indirect contact with an individual's mind, which gives you a sense of
店员更少，而且他不再向顾客提供赊账服务，而是期望顾客当场付款。价格也将清晰透明。杂货店里的每件商品将首次标有价格，这样顾客就不再担心被不道德的杂货商多收钱。桑德斯把他的杂货店命名为：皮格利·维格利（Piggly Wiggly）。为什么？没人知道。当被问及这个名字的来历时，桑德斯曾回答说，它是从混沌中以及与个人心灵的间接接触中诞生的，这让你对
the kind of guy he was. But usually, when he was asked why anyone would call a grocery store, Pigley Wiggly, he would answer, so people will ask that very question. The first Pigley Wiggly opened in Memphis in 1916. It was so successful that the second Piggly Wiggly opened three weeks later. Two months after that, another opened. Saunders insisted on calling it, Piggly Wiggly III, to lend his stores the, quote, royal dignity they are due. He soon began attaching a catchphrase to his storefront signs. Piggly Wiggly, all around the world. Of course, at the time, the stores were barely all around Memphis, but Saunders' business did grow phenomenally quickly. Within a year, there were 353 Piggly Wigglies around the United States.
他是个什么样的人有了一个概念。但通常，当别人问他为什么要把一家杂货店叫做“皮格利·维格利”时，他会回答：“这样人们就会问出这个问题。”第一家皮格利·维格利于1916年在孟菲斯开业。它获得了巨大的成功，三周后第二家皮格利·维格利就开业了。两个月后，又一家开业了。桑德斯坚持把它命名为“皮格利·维格利三号”，以赋予他的店铺应有的，引述：“皇室的尊严”。他很快开始在店面招牌上附加一句宣传语：皮格利·维格利，遍及全世界。当然，当时这些店在孟菲斯都还没怎么铺开，但桑德斯的业务确实以惊人的速度增长。一年之内，全美各地就有了353家皮格利·维格利。
In newspaper advertisements, Saunders wrote of his self-service concept in nearly Messianic terms. One day, Memphis shall be proud of Piggly Wiggly, one ad-read, and it shall be said by all men that the Piggly Wigglys shall multiply and replenish the earth with more and cleaner things to eat. Another time, he wrote, the mighty pulse of the throbbing today makes new things out of old and new things where was nothing before. Basically, Saunders spoke of Piggly Wiggly as today's Silicon Valley executives talk of their companies. We're not just making money here. We are replenishing the earth. Piggly Wiggly in the self-service grocery stores that followed did lower prices, which meant there was more to eat.
在报纸广告中，桑德斯用近乎弥赛亚般的语言来描述他的自助概念。其中一则广告写道：“总有一天，孟菲斯将为皮格利·维格利感到骄傲，所有人都会说，皮格利·维格利将繁衍并用更多、更干净的食物充满大地。”另一次，他写道：“汹涌的今日之强劲脉搏，将陈旧化为新物，在曾经空无一物的地方创造新物。”基本上，桑德斯谈论皮格利·维格利的方式，就像今天硅谷高管谈论他们的公司一样。我们在这里不只是赚钱。我们在滋养大地。皮格利·维格利以及随之而来的自助杂货店确实降低了价格，这意味着有更多的食物可吃了。
They also changed the kinds of foods that were readily available. To save costs and limit spoilage, Piggly Wiggly stocked less fresh produce than traditional grocery stores. Pre-packaged processed foods became more popular and less expensive, which altered American diets. Brand recognition also became extremely important because food companies had to appeal directly to shoppers, which led to the growth of consumer-oriented food advertising on radio and in newspapers, a phenomenon that Saunders understood better than almost anyone. During the late 19 teens and early 20s, Piggly Wiggly was the single largest newspaper advertiser
它们还改变了随手可得的食物种类。为了节省成本并减少变质，皮格利·维格利储备的新鲜农产品比传统杂货店要少。预包装加工食品变得更受欢迎且更便宜，这改变了美国人的饮食习惯。品牌知名度也变得极为重要，因为食品公司必须直接吸引购物者，这引领了广播和报纸中以消费者为导向的食品广告的发展，这一现象被桑德斯比几乎任何人都理解得更透彻。在1910年代末和20年代初，皮格利·维格利是全美
in the United States. Of course, lower prices and fewer clerks also meant that many people lost their jobs, including my great grandfather. There's nothing new about our fear that automation and increased efficiency will deprive humans of work. In one newspaper advertisement, Saunders imagined a woman torn between her long-time relationship with her friendly grocer, and the woe-woe prices of Pigley Wiggly.
最大的单一报纸广告商。当然，更低的价格和更少的店员也意味着许多人失去了工作，包括我的曾祖父。我们对自动化和提高效率会剥夺人类工作的担忧并不是什么新鲜事。在一则报纸广告中，桑德斯描绘了一个女人在左右为难，她一方面留恋与友好的杂货商长期以来的关系，另一方面又心仪皮格利·维格利那低廉的价格。
The story concluded with Saunders appealing to a tradition even older than the full service grocer, with his protagonist saying, Now away back many years there had been a Dutch grandmother of mine who had been thrifty. The spirit of that old grandmother asserted itself just then within me and said, business is business, and charity and alms are another. Whereupon our shopper saw the light and converted to Piggly Wiggly. By 1922, there were over 1,000 Piggly Wiggly stores around the US, and shares in the company were listed on the New York Stock Exchange.
故事的结局是，桑德斯借助了一个比全套服务杂货商更古老的传统来打动人心，他的主角说道：“很久很久以前，我有一位很节俭的荷兰祖母。那位老祖母的精神当时在我体内苏醒了，并说道：生意归生意，慈善和施舍是另一码事。”于是我们的购物者茅塞顿开，皈依了皮格利·维格利。到1922年，全美各地已有1000多家皮格利·维格利商店，公司的股票也在纽约证券交易所上市。
Saunders was building a 36,000 square foot mansion in Memphis, and had endowed the school now known as Rhodes College. But the good times would not last. After a few pigly wiggly stores in the northeast failed, investors began shorting the stock, betting that its price would fall. Saunders responded by trying to buy up all the available shares of Pigly Wiggly using borrowed money, but the gambit failed spectacularly, and Saunders lost control of Piggly Wiggly and went bankrupt. His vitriol at Wall Street short sellers pre-saged contemporary corporate titans just as his
桑德斯在孟菲斯建造了一座3.6万平方英尺的豪宅，并资助了如今被称为罗兹学院的学校。但好景不长。在东北部的几家皮格利·维格利商店倒闭后，投资者开始做空该股票，押注其价格会下跌。桑德斯的回应是试图通过借来的钱买下所有可流通的皮格利·维格利股票，但这场豪赌以惨败告终，桑德斯失去了对皮格利·维格利公司的控制并宣告破产。他对华尔街做空者的愤怒预示了当代企业巨头们的行径，正如他对
reliance on big advertising and hyper-efficiency did. Saunders was by many accounts of bully, verbally abusive, cruel, and profoundly convinced of his own genius. After losing control of the company, he wrote, they have it all, everything I built, the greatest stores of their kind in the world, but they didn't get the man that was father to the idea. They have the body of Piggly Wiggly, but they didn't get the soul. Saunders quickly developed a new concept for a grocery store. This one would have aisles and self-service, but also clerks in the meat department and the bakery, basically a contemporary supermarket. In under a year, he was ready to open, but the new owners of Piggly Wiggly took
大型广告和超级效率的依赖一样。根据多方记载，桑德斯是个恃强凌弱的人、言语虐待狂、冷酷无情，并且对自己的天才深信不疑。在失去公司控制权后，他写道：“他们拥有一切，我建造的一切，世界上同类中最伟大的商店，但他们没有得到作为这个理念之父的那个人。他们得到了皮格利·维格利的躯壳，却没有得到灵魂。”桑德斯迅速构思出了一个全新的杂货店概念。这个概念将拥有通道和自助服务，但在肉类和面包部门配备店员，这基本上就是当代超级市场的雏形。在不到一年的时间里，他准备好开业了，但皮格利·维格利的新老板们把他
him to court, arguing that the use of the Clarence Sunders name in relation to a new grocery store would violate Piggly Wiggly's trademarks and patents. In response, Saunders defiantly named his new grocery store, the Clarence Saunders' sole owner of my name store, perhaps the only business name worse than Piggly Wiggly. And yet, it succeeded tremendously, and Saunders made a second fortune as Sol owner stores spread throughout the South. He went on to invest in a professional football team in Memphis, which he named the Clarence Saunders Sol owner of my name Tigers.
告上了法庭，辩称在开设新杂货店时使用“克拉伦斯·桑德斯”这个名字将侵犯皮格利·维格利的商标和专利。作为回应，桑德斯挑衅性地将他的新杂货店命名为：“克拉伦斯·桑德斯——我姓名的唯一拥有者”杂货店，这或许是唯一一个比“皮格利·维格利”还要难听的商业名称。然而，它取得了巨大的成功，随着“唯一拥有者”商店在南方各地蔓延，桑德斯赚取了他的第二笔财富。接着，他投资了孟菲斯的一支职业足球队，并将其命名为“克拉伦斯·桑德斯——我姓名的唯一拥有者老虎队”。
Really. They played the Green Bay Packers and the Chicago Bears in front of huge crowds in Memphis, and they were invited to join the NFL. But Saunders declined because he didn't want to share revenue or sent his team to away games. He promised to build a stadium for the Tigers that would seat over 30,000 people. The stadium, he wrote, will have skull and crossbones for my enemies who I have slain. But within a few years, the sole owner stores were crushed by the Depression, the football team was out of business, and he was broke again. Meanwhile, the soulless body of Piggly Wiggly
真的。他们在孟菲斯吸引了庞大的观众群体，与绿湾包装工队和芝加哥熊队进行了比赛，并被邀请加入美国国家橄榄球联盟（NFL）。但桑德斯拒绝了，因为他不想分享收入，也不想派他的球队去打客场比赛。他承诺为老虎队建造一个能容纳3万人以上的体育场。他写道：“这座体育场将为被我斩杀的敌人们树立骷髅和交叉骨标志。”但几年之内，“唯一拥有者”商店就被大萧条摧毁了，橄榄球队关门大吉，他又一次破产了。与此同时，那个没有灵魂的皮格利·维格利躯壳
was faring quite well without Saunders. By the supermarket chain's height in 1932, there were over 2,500 Piggly Wigglies in the United States. And even today, there are over 600, mostly in the south. Although, like many grocery stores, they are struggling under pressure from the likes of Walmart and Dollar General, which can undercut traditional grocery stores on price, partly by providing even West fresh food and fewer clerks than today's Piggly Wigglies do. These days Piggly Wiggly ads tend to focus on tradition and the human touch. One North Alabama Piggly Wiggly TV spot from 1999 included this line. At Piggly Wiggly,
没有桑德斯也过得相当不错。到了这家超市连锁店在1932年的鼎盛时期，全美有超过2500家皮格利·维格利。甚至在今天，仍有600多家，主要分布在南部。尽管像许多杂货店一样，它们正在沃尔玛和达元（Dollar General）等竞争对手的压力下苦苦挣扎，这些竞争对手可以通过提供甚至更少的新鲜食品和比今天的皮格利·维格利更少的店员，在价格上压倒传统杂货店。如今，皮格利·维格利的广告往往侧重于传统和人情味。1999年北阿拉巴马州的一则皮格利·维格利电视广告中包含了这样一句台词：在皮格利·维格利，
it's all about friends, serving friends. A call to the kind of human-to-human relationships that Saunders ridiculed in that Dutch grandmother ad. The mighty pulse of the throbbing today does make new things out of old, but it also makes old things out of new. Today, food prices are lower relative to average wage than they've ever been in the United States, but our diets are often poor. The average American ingests more sugar and sodium than they should, largely because of processed, prepackaged foods. As for Clarence Saunders, he spent decades after his second bankruptcy trying to launch a new concept called the
一切为了朋友，服务朋友。这是在呼唤那种桑德斯在那则荷兰祖母广告中嘲笑的人与人之间的关系。汹涌的今日之强劲脉搏确实将陈旧化为新物，但它也将新物化为陈旧。如今，相对于平均工资而言，美国的食品价格比以往任何时候都要低，但我们的饮食往往很糟糕。由于加工的预包装食品，普通美国人摄入的糖和钠超过了应有的水平。至于克拉伦斯·桑德斯，他在第二次破产后的几十年里，一直试图推出一个名为
Key Doosle, a totally automated store that looked like a massive bank of vending machines and involved purchasing food with almost no human to human interaction. He was also one of the first business people to spend private money on newspaper advertising for political candidates, running ads, including virulently racist ones for his preferred gubernatorial candidates. Saunders grew more vitriolic and unpredictable as he aged. He could never get the key doosle to work, the machinery broke down constantly, and people found the shopping experience slow and clunky.
“Key Doo"sle”的新概念——一个全自动商店，看起来像是一排大型自动售货机，买东西几乎不涉及人与人之间的互动。他也是最早将私人资金用于为政治候选人投放报纸广告的商界人士之一，投放的广告中包括为他青睐的州长候选人宣传的极度种族主义广告。随着年龄的增长，桑德斯变得越来越尖酸刻薄、喜怒无常。他始终无法让“Key Doosle”运作起来，机器不断故障，人们觉得这种购物体验缓慢而笨拙。
He eventually entered a sanitarium that treated people with anxiety and depression. The mansion Saunders built with his first fortune became the Pink Palace Museum, Memphis's Science and History Museum. The estate he built with his second fortune became Lickderman Nature Center. In 1936 the journalist Ernie Pyle said, if Saunders lives long enough, Memphis will become the most beautiful city in the world, just with the thing Saunders built and lost. But Saunders never made a third fortune. He died at the Walla Sanitarium in 1953 at the age of 72. One obituary opined, at the age of 72. One obituary opined, some men achieved lasting fame through success,
他最终住进了一家治疗焦虑和抑郁症的疗养院。桑德斯用他的第一笔财富建造的豪宅变成了粉红宫殿博物馆（Pink Palace Museum），即孟菲斯的科学与历史博物馆。他用第二笔财富建造的庄园变成了利克德曼自然中心（Lickderman Nature Center）。1936年，记者厄尼·派尔（Ernie Pyle）说：“如果桑德斯活得够久，孟菲斯将成为世界上最美丽的城市，仅仅凭借桑德斯建造和失去的东西。”但桑德斯再也没有赚到第三笔财富。1953年，他在瓦拉疗养院去世，享年72岁。一篇讣告写道：享年72岁。一篇讣告写道：有些人通过成功获得不朽的名声，
others achieved it through failure. Saunders was a huckster. He committed securities fraud. He helped usher in an era of food that fills without nourishing. He was also a genius ahead of his time, who understood the power of branding and efficiency. But mostly, when I think of Piggly Wiggly, I think of it swallowing up the small town grocery stores, only to be swallowed itself by the likes of Walmart, which will in turn be swallowed by the likes of Amazon. Joyce called Ireland the South that eats her feral, but Ireland has nothing on American capitalism. I give pigly wiggly two and a half stars. The Anthropocene Review is written by John Green, edited by Stan Muller and produced
另一些人则通过失败获得名声。桑德斯是个推销员。他犯下了证券欺诈罪。他帮助开启了一个充饥却不提供营养的食品时代。他也是一个超越时代的奇才，深谙品牌和效率的力量。但总的来说，每当我想起皮格利·维格利时，我想到的都是它吞噬了小镇杂货店，却最终自身也被沃尔玛之类的巨头吞噬，而沃尔玛又将转而被亚马逊之类的巨头吞噬。乔伊斯称爱尔兰是“那个吞食自己孩子的母猪”，但爱尔兰跟美国资本主义比起来简直小巫见大巫。我给皮格利·维格利打两星半。“人类世纪实”由约翰·格林撰写，斯坦·穆勒剪辑，并由
by Rosiana Halce-Rohas and Tony Phillips. Joe Plurd is their technical director, Hannah Brown, makes the music. The Anthropocene Review is a co-production of Complexly and WNYC Studios. Every episode is a jam, find it, and download it wherever you get your podcasts. 99% of visible was produced this week by Chris Baroube, Mixing Tech Production by Sheree Fusef, Music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is the senior producer of Kirk Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Hall, Avery Trauffman, Taren Masat, Emmett Fitzgerald,
作者为罗斯安娜·哈尔斯-罗哈斯和托尼·菲利普斯。乔·普勒德担任技术总监，汉娜·布朗负责音乐。《人类世评论》是 Complexly 与 WNYC Studios 联合制作的节目。每一集都精彩绝伦，请在各大播客平台搜索并下载。本周的《99% Invisible》由克里斯·巴鲁贝制作，混音与技术制作由谢里·富塞夫完成，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔担任高级制作人，柯克·科尔斯特德担任数字总监。团队其他成员包括高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔、埃弗里·特劳夫曼、塔伦·马萨特、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德，
Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatskert, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find mall at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or a Gron Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too.
薇薇安·李、索菲亚·克拉茨克特、乔·罗森伯格以及我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山 91.7K ALW 的项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心电台录制。99% Invisible 是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚决独立的集合。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解详情。您可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，也可以@节目 99PI，或者在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上关注我们。
But we'll have links to the Anthropocene Reviewed and the entire catalog of 99PI episodes that John says inspired him to make the Anthropocene Reviewed. I hesitate to say this because I know how it's going to sound, but when I was thinking about what I wanted to do in terms of podcasting, I thought a lot about the way that 99% invisible approaches stories and that concept of always reading the plaque. If you pay really close attention to something, you can generally learn in unexpected and exciting ways. All on the website. It's 99pi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但我们将在网站上提供《人类世评论》的链接，以及约翰表示启发他创作《人类世评论》的全部 99PI 节目目录。我犹豫要不要说这个，因为我知道听起来会怎么样，但当我思考自己在播客方面想做些什么时，我深思了《99% Invisible》处理故事的方式，以及“永远去阅读铭牌”这一理念。如果你对某事给予真正的密切关注，你通常能以意想不到的兴奋方式学到东西。所有内容都在网站上。网址是 99pi.org。来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。